matt john congratulations you two have
made it to the final round of this
competition which means you're closer
to that check for ten thousand dollars
in the title of forge and fire champion
but you're not quite there yet you still
have to go home and recreate an iconic
weapon from history are you ready to see
what that weapon is sure all right that
weapon is
that is a maasai lion spirit
the maasai lion spear gets its name from
an east african tribe of fearsome
warrior nomads that date their origins
back to the 15th century traditionally
used to hunt lions the weapon features a
double-edged blade at one end and a
fearsome spike at the other this allows
a maasai warrior to engage his opponent
in close quarters or at a distance
while today lion hunts have been
replaced the deadly spear lives on in
popular culture and can even be spotted
in the film laura croft tomb raider the
cradle of life
your job is to recreate a functional and
working version of this blade however we
want you to put your own spin on it good
luck blade smiths we'll see you in five
days
my name is john grady hipper i'm from
coast canada texas by trade i am a
combination pop welder each knife i make
has its own personality when i hand the
customer a knife
brings me all the joy in the world so
i'm playing with my baby girl and i
realized that i left this socket in the
forge too long
he got hot and it just fell to the
ground melted my whole socket's gone
i've just wasted this huge amount of
time right now i'm just gonna forget
about this whole socket deal i'm gonna
grab this rebar and start forging the
spike if this heat streak goes the way i
think it's gonna go i'm gonna be sitting
very well time wise turn and burn baby
let's go let's move fast
it does get a significant warp i really
don't know what to do
ah
it looks like it's got a real sharp
curve to it it's just it's bad
really i was speechless i didn't know
what to do i might have to start a whole
another piece i realized that let's just
end it here
let's start anew
so i like the propane forge and start up
that's some big old stuff right there
now i probably lost about a whole day on
this blade portion i am war smooth out
i'm trying to do a lot of things at once
i've got a 25 inch handle that i need to
make
get everything normalized if the blade
warps hopefully i've got enough material
to fix it and i'm going to make this
thing work come hell or high water
ah dad gummy it snaps i just i'm shocked
i'm speechless i just don't know what to
do i'm bummed i am bummed bum-bum so
i've got two main options one option
would be to go back to the first blade
i think i'm gonna to go with another
option that's to take weld it i'm just
gonna have to push through this
my name's matthew berry i'm 55 years old
i was a computer programmer and i
retired because i could
when the other placements see me they're
probably gonna say ah he's an old guy i
need a flake all right he's not a
problem but who knows you know it's an
adventure i've got the startup socket
and so now i need to start flaring it
i'm hitting it a lot and it's just not
moving much so i decided i needed to try
something different
this is called a portuguese steak all
right let's see what this can do for me
so i try flaring it with that
and it flared
you can come off
as it's cooling it's going to shrink so
now i'm a little panicked about this if
i can't get this off well i've lost
at least two hours work right there
tool for every occasion
so i finished the heat treat on the
slashing blade and it came out great so
i'm going to get to work on the handle
i'm going to use ash for the handle
that's what they make most baseball bats
out of
so if the handle is going to break
anywhere it's going to break right at
the base of the socket where they
connect but i think it's thick enough
that it's going to hold up i just don't
see that being a problem
i test fit the spike and the blade on
my blade's crooked i got to do something
about this i can't send this down to the
judges
oh
no i know i
realized that all i have to do is
rotate the spearhead 180 degrees hey
much better perfect
so crisis is averted i'm psyched it
looks like this is going to go together
and be really sweet
placements this is the kill test to see
how lethal your weapon is i will take
your spear and deliver lethal blows on
this big carcass
mat you're up first are you ready
ready as i'll ever be let's do this
what i'm most worried about is lateral
force on this spear because it's a very
thin sleek spear
[Music]
so
well
that sucks
matt i'm not gonna sugarcoat it this is
bad
your weapon has suffered a catastrophic
failure and cannot continue with testing
however
john we can't just declare you the
forged and fire champion your blade has
to hold up for at least a stab and a
slash on this carcass doug
[Music]
i don't know what to say i don't know
what to think i've never been more you
know nervous in high life
i'm hoping and praying that he doesn't
break in the same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bladesmiths as their design these tests
push your weapons to the limit
john your blade survived the two cuts on
our carcass
matt that means unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut i have to ask you
to please leave the forge
congrats man i'm happy for you
i'm disappointed given what i know now i
would have gone back and really tried
chopping some things very hard with the
spear and hopefully broken the handle
myself
i'm really happy for john maybe i'm not
happy to lose to john but i'm glad john
won
john congratulations you built a weapon
that held up in our test that makes you
our new forged and fire champion who
also receives a check for 10 grand
how do you feel right now uh i feel like
a million bucks but i guess 10 grand
will do all right well come on over here
and shake our hands good job but thanks
very good i want to have to uh talk to
my wife about what i'm allowed to to do
with this prize money i know one thing
my baby girl girl's gonna get a little
new wardrobe
you